leavon welcome uh to the show this
tournament so far hasn't uh been yours
but definitely still plenty of chest to
be played tell us your assessment of
this event so far and what are you going
to do to uh turn it around as
well well uh you know I'm learning
trying new things so uh it's a part of
the process you know part of the
learning process so sometimes the result
don't come uh but uh you know as long as
there's a plan you know I I kind of uh
see the light in the end of the tunnel
speaking of the process and trying to
learn new things yesterday you uh played
the Sicilian we haven't seen you play
the Sicilian in a very long time in a
classical uh game of chess how did you
come up with that
decision I thought um I have some you
know events coming so um that are going
to be like um open uh you know shingan
system so like an open tournament so you
know you need to play the Sicilian in a
shenan tournament therefore uh I think
um you have to practice uh especially in
such an important tournament so when the
pressure is there yeah you you you need
to try and and play the the new openings
you know it's easy to play new openings
in a Blitz game where nothing really
matters but uh you need to practice this
type of openings U that are new to you
in in a combat kind of simulation mode
absolutely tell us the story of uh
today's
game it was um fairly solid game I was
trying to put a little bit of pressure I
think
um uh I I didn't really remember what I
was intending to do in this particular
line but I thought you know it's just a
position uh I've played this type of
structures a lot uh with black so let's
try to be on a white side of it and uh I
think I managed to to put put up a
little bit of pressure but uh then I
think Wesley played well yeah things got
a bit imbalanced at some point right
after this exchange of the Pawns in
Center E5 Queen D5 how did you assess it
at this point what were the plans for
both sides in your opinion
I thought it was kind of interesting you
know with this A3 and putting this
strategical uh threat so I mean uh he he
he also has this Rook F4 instead of
Knight D7 which is very interesting you
know just uh kind of forcing me to play
uh Knight B4 takes Tak a b Queen D7 I
thought it's very very complex
strategically something that uh I
generally like to do you know
to just uh to
um game and enjoy it yes yes absolutely
and then he played This Night D7 which I
felt was also interesting and then after
C5 yeah it was kind of kind of uh
exciting here because Knight F5 I
thought Rook A6 from distance I thought
is the move but there I have this
interesting sequence excuse me yeah yeah
yeah after C5 that's all correct mhm
takes Knight G5 oh Knight G5
yeah and and here so Rook uh A6 looks
also very natural but there I have this
queen
G4 and Knight D3 and Knight H7 which is
which is very interesting yeah Knight E1
Knight f8 and queen
G2 uh uh Queen G2 Knight G2 Rook
C8 mhh yeah oh it's some sort of a race
yeah he's going to try to go D yeah some
kind of oh yeah I didn't see D3 but I
felt it was fascinating position to to
calculate all of those sties and uh
quite often as it happens you know once
uh my opponent found the correct moves
you there is not much you can do I
thought that the position is yeah rather
yeah rather solid yeah definitely a very
creative game today still plenty of
rounds to go uh we'll let you go get
some rest and we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very much thank you
uh leavon indeed that felt like almost